décision qu'on prend actuellement pour
être solidaire hypothèque drôlement
l'avenir des générations présentes et si
j'essaye effectivement d'humaniser un
peu le débat et de penser à mes grands
parents par exemple je me demande si le
meilleur service qu'on puisse leur
rendre c'est pas 2 2 les deux les de les
laisser aussi partir en se disant qu'ils
font aussi les meilleurs choix pour
garantir un avenir alors à leurs enfants
et à leurs petits enfants
moi quand j'ai ma grand-mère les
grands-mères mon grand père au téléphone
oui ils se gagnent un peu leur situation
n'est pas tellement ils sont surtout
très inquiet pour moi pour mes enfants
pour le monde qu'ils laissent derrière
eux donc de ce point de vue là aussi
pour modérer un peu ce que ce que disait
gaspard koenig je pense que c'est une
génération ou pas juger
rétrospectivement de leurs faits et
gestes
mais qui c'est une génération qui est
très inquiète parce qu'ils se rendent
bien compte que la vie qu'ils ont connue
ne pourront pas la garantir aux
générations suivantes et j'entends aussi
beaucoup de culpabilité mois chez nos
anciens nous est né appelez les comme
vous voulez et je me dis que un service
à leur rendre
c'est aussi de leur de les aider à
appréhender à mort un pas se crisper
contre cela parce que effectivement elle
va bien finir par arriver à un moment ou
un autre et quand j'entends certaines
personnes me dire mais il est pas view
il a 80 ans
c'est quelque chose que j'ai vraiment
entendu plusieurs fois je me demande si
c'est vraiment un service à rendre aux
personnes âgées que leur faire croire
qu'elles pourront comme ça a continué
les vie en bonne santé pendant encore
une durée limitée donc je me demande si
d'un point de vue philosophique
ce virus est pas une occasion de voilà
de penser collectivement notre rapport à
nous
[Musique]